depuis 23 ans le Festival du film de
vandô met en lumière de jeunes
réalisateurs cette année c'est sous le
signe du court-métrage d'animation qu'il
s'est placé explication avec Émilie
parz Émilie paré vous êtes délégué
général le festival il est reconnu au
niveau national et et européen il y a
près de 200 films programmés cette année
qu'est-ce qui fait le succès et et
comment on organise un festival de cette
ampleur c'est un travail quand même de
longue haleine et notamment dans le
repérage des films c'est vrai que on se
déplace en festival on essaie d'être
plusieurs aussi pour composer une
programmation pour avoir une richesse
une culture voilà pour pouvoir composer
vraiment les programmes et puis ce qui
fait le succès bah j'espère que c'est
une qualité artistique de la
programmation on essaie d'avoir une
ligne éditoriale assez exigeante
accessible à tous mais quand même assez
ambitieuse et on est vraiment le
festival depuis 23 ans est vraiment dans
le l'idée de de chercher de défricher et
de proposer un renouvellement des
talents Anatole traîne toujours derrière
lui sa petite casserole
elle lui est tombé dessus un jour on ne
sait pas très bien
pourquoi à cause de cette petite
casserole Anatole n'est plus tout à fait
comme les
autres alors vous êtes intéressé cette
année au court-métrage d'animation pour
quelle raison depuis une quinzaine
d'années cyclique qui organise le
festival soutient le le cinéma
d'animation en accueillant en fait des
tournages de court-métrage qui viennent
pour l'instant dans des locaux à Château
Renault et en 2015 il y a un très beau
projet qui est en train d'être réalisé
qui est en travaux actuellement av vô
pour une résidence et des des plateaux
plus beau plus grand dans un beau lieu
de patrimoine ici à vandô et on avait
vraiment envie que le public vandomois
sache ce qui se passait sur son
territoire notamment avec une une
exposition qui s'appelle les métiers du
cinéma d'animation c'est à la chapelle
Saint-Jacques c'est ouvert tous les
après-midis et c'est gratuit c'est un
parcours un peu enfin très ludique pour
les spectateurs pour les visiteurs ça
explique un peu les les coulisses et
l'envers du décor de la fabrication d'un
court-métrage
d'animation les films sélectionnés
viennent de partout en France et vous
attachez une
importance capitale à la production
régionale vous vous pouvez nous en dire
de mots c'est vrai qu'il y a des auteurs
et des productions qui se trouvent en
région Centre alors on n'est pas un
festival régionaliste mais quand les
films sont de très bonne qualité et de
très bonnes factur ben on a envie de les
montrer et de les faire participer au
panorama du cinéma français européen
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que par
exemple en compétition cette année on a
un film qui s'appelle h balles de Franck
Ternier c'est un film d'animation qui a
été entièrement réalisé et tourné à tour
il a démarré au festival de Cann à la
section de la Quinzaine des réalisateurs
et je crois que maintenant il en est
bientôt à son 50e
Festival depuis quelques mois j'aime
bien me rendre au Blue Note pour
descendre quelqu
peintte un homme d'une trentaine
d'années boit une bière une Taiwan B
c'est un français exilé pour affaire il
boit une autre
bière des idées de sortie cette semaine
il n'y en a pas qu'avant
petit tour
d'horizon le chanteur Patrice poursuit
la tournée de son dernier album The
Rising of the sun un mélange de regéga
de sa de blues et de
Hipop coup fatal ou comment revisiter la
musique baroque le conteténor Serge
kakui est accompagné de 13 musiciens de
Kinshasa la mise en danse signé par le
chorégraphe belge Alain
Platel keV tu vas voir cette année tu
vas avoir des cours de techno et puis
parce qu'il en faut pour tous les goûts
le jeune humoriste Kev Adams sera à tour
avec son nouveau show voilà voil techno
j'allais rentrer dans la salle j'allais
voir
ça sortez vos
CAH c'est termin pour cette semaine je
vous rappelle que le festival du film de
vendô c'est jusqu'au 12 décembre c'est
ça Gérard oui jusqu'au 12 décembre
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel
agenda